hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host grace and
Helbig today we have Tablo with us he
has done anything that you could think
of in the entertainment industry other
than his own line of whiskey you'll hear
why he also had a terrible
gastrointestinal problem in Arizona but
other than that he's a highly acclaimed
rapper musician author father husband
etc so enjoy this episode of not too
deep with Tablo you ever in the mood for
a great tasting beer but not the buzz or
the hangover that comes with it enter
Brooklyn breweries special effects a
delicious flavorful brand-new brew that
happens to be non-alcoholic special
effects is not just for folks who don't
drink alcohol it's for anyone who wants
to do more with their days and nights so
head to Brooklyn Brewery calm slash
special effects for more info and to see
it where you can pick up a six-pack or
two near you Tablo thank you for being
here thank you for having me here yeah
you're here because I couldn't get your
daughter oh yes this is the replacement
my my last like nine years of my career
and she's nine
yeah she's nine so the last nine years
of my career have been like as you know
that yeah people try to get her well
that um she's perfect
yeah she's great yeah what's it like to
raise a perfect daughter it's like I'm
her friend I'm her friend you're her
peer that's perfect peers yeah she just
looks at me as like this you know not so
perfect person yeah to just have fun
with is she developing a desire to get
into entertainment at all she likes
dancing so Shan Singh she's actually
really into Billy Irish oh cool um so I
found her like learning the dances and
she's into a lot of like kpop girl group
yeah
choreography so she's like her graphing
herself and like just doing crazy dances
and then I asked her I was like hey do
you want to do music do you want to do
like kpop or whatever yeah when you grow
up and she's like no really yeah and I'm
like then why are you learning the
dances she's like because it's fun does
that hurt your heart or is that actually
a kind of like that's cool for me she
can do whatever she wants yeah and then
I also caught her like making YouTube
videos where she was doing what you
caught her making YouTube videos she she
closed the door and I could hear her
like you know talking to like yeah yeah
so I knocked and she let me in and I was
like can I see what you're making and
she's like yeah and she played it for me
and I'm like this is great and she was
doing a lot of acting too on on this
YouTube show that is not ever being
aired right this is just for her yeah
and I'm like so do you want to go into
acting like your mom and she's like no
really and I'm like then why you doing
this she's like it's fun so she's
getting all the things her parents do
for a living out of her system at eight
or nine years old and then she's gonna
end up being some like amazing scientist
yes she says she wants to go into saving
animals oh so I said so like a vet and
she's like no no no not just a vet like
I want to be able to like go out and
literally save a lot of animals amazing
yeah so she wants to be a vet slash like
animal rescuer this is gonna be that can
dance and rap she's gonna oh so she's
gonna be a triple threat she's gonna act
dance and sacred and do YouTube and do
YouTube Wow called drupal threat here's
my well my actual first question for you
mmm-hmm are you tired
what do you mean in life in general I
tired with life tired with how much
stuff you've done in your entire life
today sometimes I get worried that other
people will get tired of it yeah I'm not
tired of it yet
great um I'm always looking for the next
thing to do and I always have things
like in motion mm-hmm but I
I do have like a constant fear that
other people will get tired of it right
I've seen too much of me or from having
like years of my music yeah so I think
that's why I take time in between albums
sometimes we take like two three years
because you guys let's let's talk about
just like from the beginning for people
that might be listening that don't know
you at all so you started your you've
you've moved around a ton when you were
younger
yes but then you landed in Vancouver so
first I was born in Seoul mm-hmm
immediately taken to Jakarta okay which
I don't think is like safe
I don't think parents are supposed to do
that yeah it doesn't seem like yeah like
not just to take like that like an
infant like on a plane yeah
but they clearly didn't care they met
your parents to do it so I grew up in
Jakarta for a little while
apparently Indonesian was the like that
language was the first language I
learned Wow and then I went to Korea at
some at a certain point and then I ended
up in Vancouver okay I like that you say
at a certain point at some point I was
in Korea and it's annoying I was evicted
I was also in Hong Kong and like Europe
for a little bit like my parents make my
childhood a mystery yes like they won't
tell me the exact details on what
happens then you get to go I don't know
if I had dreamt this or this was reality
so but I do remember like from Vancouver
on I have a very good memory of like
what happened okay so in Vancouver is
that where you started doing music oh no
no no I started doing music pretty much
in high school in Seoul in Seoul yes I
started off by it actually wasn't like
music music I was writing poetry at the
time okay and somehow a very famous
musician in Korea at the time he was you
know like the most famous musician in
Korea mhm and he somehow got in my
poetry in his hands I don't know how
they happened because I was just a high
school kid
Wow I guess it traveled hands and got to
him
okay and then he was trying to do a song
in English and he wanted the lyrics to
be very poetic and he you know just
called up and hired me to write lyrics
he called you on the phone yeah do you
remember that phone yeah I was like that
because I didn't have a cell phone it's
right no one that cell phone internet
doesn't exist at this time right yeah
yeah you gotta be at the phone like at
that specific time huh and if you're
like a minute late you might miss the
call that changes your life unless you
have an answering machine yeah so I got
the call and I didn't believe that it
was you know for real yeah and and
absolutely like I wasn't too into like
becoming a musician or anything like
that okay I just like writing a lot so I
went over and started working on the
lyrics and the album came out during
winter break okay and I went back to
school and here did you tell your
friends that this had happened no but
here's where my life changed okay so
before this happened before the winter
break like I was popular among kids just
as you know like a fun guy to be with a
group of friends and stuff yeah there
were certain healthy social life certain
girls you know might have may have
thought that I was cute but it wasn't
like I wasn't like a big deal right and
then winter break happened and this
album came out and word spread that you
know Daniel uh-huh I was Daniel at the
time yeah he's writing lyrics for this
guy and is in music now and then I get
back to school and I was like super
popular Wow like what a weird thing yeah
our school had like elementary to high
school yeah all like all in a couple
buildings so you guys all grew up
together and yeah and there were like
middle school like kids like you know
like coming to the high school building
to get a glimpse of the guy that is in
music now Wow
and at the time I was like oh so this is
what happens if you do music I'm gonna
be I'm gonna be a singer-songwriter
this is the coolest feeling like care
about me
I am noticed and that's I think that's
one of the reasons why I like sort of
gone into music in a way Wow that's not
very unique yeah and very and shallow Oh
I mean why we're all [ __ ] narcissist
that's why we're all here it's all the
same thing don't even worry about it
I was like good but also he's like me
now yeah I want to be liked by more
girls do I do that okay so how did epic
hi come in to play and then I ended up
in college and while I was in college I
did like an underground group like just
for fine okay and then one of the demos
I made again changed hands you have this
magic touch yeah I guess I'm you know
nobody knows how it gets out so my demo
circulated a little bit and somehow got
into certain agencies in Korea okay
and I was they contacted me they were
like can you come in because we wanna
like talk about having you as an artist
Wow and this was while I was in college
so during breaks I would go back to
Seoul and I I went to some of these what
were you studying in college at the time
English Lit okay so a lot of people were
telling me like you know with that major
you're gonna have to figure out quick
like what you're gonna do after right
yeah yeah so I I went back and did like
some editions I didn't know it was gonna
be an audition okay I went in they made
me like wrap and then they're like can
you sing a little bit I sang a little
bit they're like can you dance how I'm
like I don't dance
and I they try to put me in a like a boy
band at a certain point they oh really
yeah one of these companies okay and
it's a it's a huge company yeah
and I I was like I'm not for that like I
I for you I don't think I'm good enough
to do that I know my abilities I can
only wrap if they want to dance around
me if I'm the center and everyone's
dancing around me so I went back to
school thinking I wouldn't you know be a
be a musician and I was like maybe I'll
be a novelist or going to film a dream I
know I wanted to keep writing yeah and
then the word spread I guess and someone
else wanted me on to be an artist and
then I was like maybe I'll try it for a
couple of years mm-hmm
after graduation and and then it led to
this Wow yeah wait okay
so epic high Oh epic high so after so
the last year that I had left in college
yeah I was in Seoul for winter break and
somebody was like hey you know like do
you want to be in our hip-hop group you
know and it was Mithra and this this
producer okay and I was like well I
gotta go back and finish school first
yeah I don't know for you it sounds like
fun you have all these casual amazing
opportunities that just enter your
universe and you're like maybe I guess
that's cool and I went back to school
and I did we started making songs over
like MS messenger Microsoft Messenger
yeah like I actually met the DJ that's
in our team DJ two cuts huh I didn't
even meet him like the first thing I got
from this kid was like him his mix set
right and he was like doing scratches
and stuff and I was like this is really
cool we need a DJ in our team yeah and
so it was like we did it all over this
messenger thing where we would send
lyrics to each other
that's nuts and then by the time school
ended and I came back we were already a
group wow really yeah so he told are you
at this time this was a right after
college so like I was I had just turned
21 Wow and so it was like internet
dating in a way yeah
we were you were saying ASL to each
other but like like location song it was
very tender ish yeah like that's how we
met and then we became a team and you
know we've been together since wow
that's so so you guys have been together
for 20 20 years
no um so 16 10 since 2002 so we met in
2001 but truly met as 3 in 2002 so
that's 17 years 17 years yeah yeah
that's so pumping awfully long time
heads I mean how how how how I don't
know I I mean do you guys have a limit
on how much time you can be around each
other now they spend way too much time
together yeah with the tours and stuff
yeah the North American tour where we
were on a bus together for like a month
oh so that's a lot of time to be
spending with people there it's the
grossest thing that happened on the bus
well
nothing grows happened because you
couldn't go number two on the boat
that's my actual inference of that
question yeah that was difficult thing
for me it's just like telling someone
that they need to pull over well I feel
I've kept feeling bad because her driver
you know he has to like that's a long
drive yeah and you're driving like while
you guys are sleeping right across a
desert yes stuff and like it was in
Arizona I think I felt horrible having
to like ask him to find a place I can
stop yeah and he did find a place for me
to stop and I try to go and it was not a
place you know I just like it was it was
the wrong place to be for me
uh-huh and I was I was just I was
shocked by what I saw and I ran back
into the bus and I was like go go go
like he's like he's like did you handle
it and I'm like no I'm not handling it
I'm just gonna hold on until I see
buildings like what I've seen horrors
that have pushed
back into meiosis I really did see some
Horrors yeah I should have been more
suspicious because like it was weird
that there was it was you know vast
plots of desert just desert just that's
it and and a tiny like cabin looking
thing yeah I shouldn't I should have
known right away that that's not you
never know unless you experienced yeah
yes you don't want to assume and so when
you get there and you really talking
about this right now I'm really
appreciative that you're talking about
this right now these are the glamorous
moments of tour that people want to know
it's all the flashing and lights on
stage and the fans and all that I want
to know that you were too grossed out to
take a [ __ ] so we're wait how long was
that tour that tour was uh like a month
just in North America was that the first
time you guys all took a bus tour to you
yes it's the first time we did a bus
tour at all
really yeah but we've always done it
with planes okay
and I hate getting on planes like every
day yeah that's exhausting um so my
manager Eddie at Ian's management
shoutout mm-hmm he's been here yeah he's
like dude you gotta do the bus tour it's
so much better
mm-hmm and for the first half of it I
was like I'm gonna kill Eddie because
these bunks I had so much trouble
sleeping in the box
yeah they look claustrophobic to me we
couldn't do number two on the bus like I
said because you have to pay like $300
or something for $500 every time you do
that wait is that for real right it's
there was a sign that's the actual tour
bus yeah because they have to hire
somebody to clean it oh it's not like an
RV yeah and every time you have to pay
like 500 bucks I felt like I wouldn't be
able to do that at all I felt like just
like maybe just paying yeah I really
like flexing take my card keep a tab
open because I don't know what I'm just
giving them like ten thousand dollars
just be like I'm going
be here for a while there's other people
on the bus too and it's like you know
you're trying to uh not make it dirty so
Wow that did you learn a lot would you
do it again I'm gonna have to do it
again you are yeah next year we're
probably gonna tour again and it's
better than a plane yeah there you go
what's the one thing that you've learned
that you're gonna switch up this time
outside of the number two situation well
don't stop in the middle of the desert
yeah it's okay to walk into a strange
cabin just someone's house and there was
someone's house it would have been
better yeah I don't want to talk about
what I it seems like it still haunts you
so can I take a quick break I just put
this last six months like suppressing
this you've been in therapy I'm sorry
that I triggered you we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back I got more
questions for you and then we're gonna
get to some Twitter questions for you
well we were a bad before not today
[Music]
today we have support from a company
that is here to support you in your
breast area that's right we got support
from third love today designed with
measurements from millions of women
third loves bra styles are made to fit
your life they have over eighty four all
sizes but know that the only one that
matters is yours you guys have heard me
talk about third love for so long but
it's only because they are so good
I wear sports bras all the time I don't
like the way bras feel I always feel a
little uncomfortable a little restrained
and third loves bras are truly so
comfortable you do not feel like you're
wearing a bra but you do feel like
you're being a thousand percent
supported it's hands-down the most
comfortable bra that your own they have
straps that don't slip
they have tag list labels and they have
lightweight memory foam cups that mold
to your shape plus returns and exchanges
are free and easy in fact thanks to
third loves perfect fit promise every
customer has 60
days to wear it wash it and put it to
the test and if you don't love it you
can return it and third-level wash it
and donate it to a woman in need it's a
win-win situation for everyone
third love knows there's a perfect bra
for everyone so right now they're
offering you guys 15% off your first
order go 2/3 love.com / grace now to
find your perfect fitting bra and get
15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com / grace for 15%
off today alright we're back what's your
deal with aliens
uh I like them you like him yeah okay um
I believe that there are aliens meet you
yeah and I don't think it has to
contradict anyone's beliefs or you know
whatever individual beliefs they have
sure I think they're they might just be
there like there's lions and tigers and
bees yeah I think it's selfish for us to
think that were the only things that
existed in the entire universe and we
are aliens to them yeah so what would
you say if you saw another life-form
like an alien life-form yeah like if it
came down to you mm that might have been
what you saw in Arizona but if it came
down to you like what how would you
communicate first thing I would say is
don't kill me please don't kill me okay
let's say hypothetically you had 30
seconds to talk to this alien this
aliens going back to its home planet and
communicating with the rest of its
culture what would you try to
communicate in those 30 seconds for it
to take back if it's hypothetically able
to understand what you're saying
I would I would spend the 30 seconds
showing him like trying to like describe
or sing something to show the beauty of
humankind give him like your mix no but
I would spend 30 seconds like trying to
describe to him the the beauty of
humankind because I am convinced that
aliens if they ever do come will for
sure either destroy us right or eat us
so that's destroying yes so I would have
to show him that we are as a species you
know
worth preserving yeah and not killing
and eating yeah yes but we're not
threatening in a way and it's a very
short time to be able to do that 30
seconds yeah but I don't know what I
would mention maybe like you know maybe
just one like Beyonce I'll be like this
is why we're worth preserving because
she's still alive right now this is this
is Kendrick Lamar have you seen this
show called killing Eve it's and then
the alien goes back and he's like with
his friends and he's like dude these
kids are hopeless he was playing weird
things trying to show me killing Eve
we've evolved so much from there are you
going to continue writing short stories
I don't know what form it'll take yeah
but you know for me writing short
stories writing poetry and writing raps
or writing songs mm-hmm to me it's all
the same thing yeah you know like I go
into it thinking exactly the same and
feeling exactly the same and like
there's something I want to say and I
just choose a medium to do that yeah
right so whether it's always through
music or you know I might one day like
write a screenplay or yeah or a play or
a musical or something yeah it doesn't
really matter what it is a musical feels
like a great yep yeah and even
podcasting like yeah when I started the
tableau podcast like you know I went
into it exactly as I would step on stage
at a show right like I'm doing it for
the fans and I'm talking to them so the
content that appears on my podcast which
would sort of be like writing for me too
you know yeah I mean does it feel at all
different to be able to be unedited in a
podcast versus like trying to be on
stage a little bit more edited I think
so like writing a song like I stress
myself out like crazy because
literally I will spend like a month
changing a word sure when no one would
notice but like I need it to be perfect
for me at least and for with podcasting
you can't do that right or your staff
will just quit
Dianne's get out of there if I'm like
okay stop go back a little bit I want to
read do that yeah they would hate it and
so it's like you say what you feel at
the time and it's out there yeah and I
actually love it
it's like improv in a way yeah yeah
you're having a conversation yeah about
your thoughts yes and you are you doing
and people are listening to other people
having conversations isn't that bizarre
it's it's bizarre but I totally
understand yeah a couple weeks ago I
actually found myself doing that I went
into this a Korean barbeque restaurant
well it was in Seoul so it's just a
barbecue barbecue restaurant and I'm
sitting there and it was a small room
where they had two tables mm-hmm so my
wife and I were at one table and right
next to us there was another you know
table yeah and they were fighting about
something and this one person I guess is
thinking about quitting her job because
her co-workers are horrible okay right
and she was telling this story to the
friend that she was with yeah and my
wife and I realized that for like an
hour
neither of us talked we were just
nodding like daughter to her story but
he was riveting the story yeah and there
were certain elements that like I could
identify with and then the girl that was
telling the story she started crying Oh
like while eating great Korean barbeque
you have dinner and the show happened
yeah she's she's like crying and I'm
about to cry
yes I'm now so invested in this story
you know and my wife and I are like oh
my god right she has no idea that you
guys are fully in there with her yeah
and that is the beauty of podcast you
know it's happening like
in real life - yeah like that's it's
great hearing people's conversations I
love it yeah it's one of my favorite
things eavesdropping and no one is safe
if you're talking out loud I'm allowed
to hear it how did you meet your wife I
met my wife first at a cell phone store
at the time I wouldn't say we met I was
stalking her no we were both getting
phones okay we didn't know we didn't
look to see who each other were uh-huh
and she was sitting next to me and
putting a screen protector on her phone
uh-huh
and she was so meticulous about it and I
could only see this person's hands
putting this thing on the on a phone
right and it was so careful that I was
watching it while waiting for my phone
and I was like you know you don't have
to put that on like you can just like it
doesn't matter right like you said yeah
you're going you know you're going
through so much trouble dressed out
about you just take it off right and she
I see the hand stop right uh-huh
and then rip it off and then the person
walked out and I was like hey you never
looked at her face the whole time
yeah I didn't right I could only see her
hand and her phone and the reason why
she stopped and walked out was my
remember two cuts was behind me uh-huh
and he he I don't know if this makes him
a douchebag but I'm sure that wasn't his
intention okay he was like yeah if it's
if it's scratches just get a new one and
this was like four months into our first
like big break okay okay are we had just
recently released a song called fly and
it was a huge success in Korea and we
had struggled up until that point so I'm
sure two cuts was like he was just like
beyond himself was bawling at the time
right so he's like if it scratches just
scare new ones and she probably thought
that this was really lame yeah and then
ripped it off and and laughed
and the person that was handing me my
phone was like that was Connie Jong yeah
the actress Connie Jung and I'm like
because I was a fan of her so I was like
oh my god
I was like too cuz she's gonna think
we're like [ __ ] you truly did not
look at her face
yeah hold we're very close together like
and there's other side by side you're
all looking at your own face
yeah so and then like a few years later
years later
yeah years later she came to a show that
I did uh-huh and I ended up finally
meeting her Wow
and then one thing led to another and
immediately a baby was born Wow this is
modern romance I'm kidding I'm kidding
but you know yeah we dated and like I
thought she would hate me so I actually
asked I was like do you remember like
like a couple years ago three years ago
like that phone yeah and she's like of
course I remember right and Wow my
wife's sister was like I thought you
guys were so lame like because did she
know who you were yeah we both knew who
we were uh like she wasn't really into
our music at the time okay and then
eventually I guess she became like a fan
of our music as yeah so she came to the
show yeah yeah okay and you know I mean
you guys should get free phones from
that phone company wherever you were for
the rest of your lives
unfortunately phones changed
dramatically since true
yeah and apples not you don't want those
flip phones
I had a Prada phone I was buying a hot
rodder phone
what's a Prada phone oh it was it it
looks like a smart phone but it's not
okay and it was like but it was like oh
it was like a co-production thing with
LG and Prada I think wow so it was a
signer phone gold and stuff I bet if you
look at it now it looks ancient
yeah but at the time it was
the coolest yeah and two cuts was like
saying you know if you scratch it just
can you I love it okay on that note
would you rather only be allowed to
watch shows and movies from your wife's
filmography or only ever be allowed to
listen to epic hi albums I choose epic I
albums not because like I love myself or
I don't want to well my wife's films yes
some of my wife's films are like pretty
disturbing and and you know she's a very
versatile actor so she's in projects
that are some projects are like really
really you know like old boy yeah and
for me to have to like keep rewatching
that it's tough yeah that well that
would not be good for my health like my
mental health yeah that might ruin the
relationship you know I have to listen
to my music all the time anyways yeah so
like when I'm on stage I'm you know just
listening to my music
it's very having to watch your way this
is Tuesday yeah I can't see old boy over
and over again okay would you trust your
manager Eddie to pull off a high-stakes
heist with you uh no no he has too much
integrity okay and usually artists will
say this about their like you know
manager yeah but he has too much
integrity and even with the tabla
podcast and like dive studios where my
podcast is being you know that Network
has way too much integrity so like
that's why like none of us are making
money everything is free I also feel
like a family like looking at your
Instagram and you're like posting videos
of him like traveling with you yeah
feels like you guys are really good
friends yeah and you know he was only
supposed to be on my podcast once in a
while but like he's now like a co-host
almost right he's like there every other
episode and like we finally made merch
right okay and even that with that like
this guy has so much integrity that he
will never sell out you know like summer
there's so many ways we could sell out
with the merch you're managing him as
your manager base and they actually take
care to like make these things which may
discuss which which is the way it should
be done discussed which is the way I
were doing but I'm just saying certain
people will do everything to sell out
yeah and make a ton of money doing it
yeah I'm not saying I would do that I
wouldn't and you wouldn't either no but
there are other people that are selling
out constantly yeah and making a ton of
money though yeah yeah yeah I mean foof
in another life yeah some of these
startups yeah and they are doing
horrible things but making a ton of
money oh yeah I've been on YouTube I
understand I would never do that no I
could never do that you know I just
don't know how no that's same I don't
have that gene in my body to let me do
that I have too much guilt and remorse
about you yeah and I also it's a also
you're a family man now too so you gotta
have integrity for your daughter
who is the one that can sell out let
your daughter's it's also a lack of
information thing yeah like I just don't
know how to sell out yeah to the Revels
tools maybe you would like if someone
sent me down and was like like Tablo
just do this and this and this and you
have a billion dollars right on and done
I would have to really think about
selling out right like if it was an XY
and Z process I obably wouldn't do it if
I was hurting somebody or something sure
but you know hurting you could think
about it though oh yeah I would have to
consider it if I just knew how yeah well
this is now an open invitation for
everyone to give you the information for
how you could sell out
see what you do with that Mark
Zuckerberg call me what is your fan
scenario like like what I mean everyone
seems extremely sweet extremely
supportive extremely like respectful in
a way do you have like a bonkers fan
story like if anyone like not even to a
terrible degree but just to like a
surprising well I feel like you probably
have something every show you guys do
yeah my fans are very diverse they say
that we are like pretty weird as people
but I think my fans are just like us
yeah you cultivate the same kind of like
personality types that was this one
thing on that was on tour so you know
you look out into the crowd like
thousands of people so you can't spot
everything sure but some people have
like these huge signs mm-hmm and there
was one sign that like you could not
avoid okay and the problem was I stepped
on stage and I spotted it immediately
because not only it wasn't that it was
huge but it it was that it wasn't small
and the message was huge
okay it was like I wanna and then you
know like very explicit not even like
using euphemisms there there are so many
other ways to even say what that person
was trying to convey yeah just flat-out
to direct message wreck like
dictionary.com you know like I don't
want you to take this in any other way I
except for what I'm trying to tell you
here and I unfortunately saw this
immediately up on stage okay and sorry
to the other thousands of fans there but
for that show I was not able to see
anything else okay and the thing is
Mithra and two cuts they don't speak
English right as well as I do fright
they're not very good at English but
they're good enough know exactly what
that sign said okay actually those are
probably the only words inning that's
two cuts nose and also in that sick in
that sequence okay in that exact
sequence so they spot it and I know he
spotted it because I look back as I'm
wrapping yeah and two cuts he's like
giving me the eye like telling me to
look over there right cuz he's shocked
yeah and mithra shocked and the whole
show was like and I think I mentioned
that during the shows I'm I'm really
sorry about that sign is like really out
there like I can't focus can you like
yeah that was the one
and also it's hilarious to me to imagine
that person in their home like
diligently making videos like their
parents maybe seeing them and being that
I made art look at making it a marker
and like taking care of with each letter
like hey you know like really filling
that in like like readjusting the edges
because like this is a little askew I
shouldn't set up with it and it gets
like ah she's like I have a blueprint in
my brain yeah
wow I mean but kudos for the execution
of an idea yes and also kudos to you
guys for you know making it through that
[ __ ] yes it was very hard it was very
hard thank you
I understand it's all out of love it's
truly all out of love yes a very dirty
filthy direct love yes okay we're gonna
take one last break and when we get back
we have Twitter questions for you which
are very impressive and fun okay I will
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
as the creators of clean beauty Bare
Minerals is driven by a philosophy that
makeup and skin care should make your
skin better not just better looking
that's why their best-selling original
foundation is made with only five
ingredients all minerals for bare
minerals to be clean without compromise
means good for skin formulas with proven
performance upgrade to clean beauty
products use the foundation finder at
bare minerals calm to find your perfect
match get 20% off when you use the promo
code not too deep bare minerals the
power of good it's holiday season and
that means a lot of new stuff will be
piling up underneath your tree or
whatever item you used to celebrate the
holidays so why not make some space by
selling the stuff you don't use anymore
on Merc re Macari is the selling app
that makes selling your stuff fast and
easy you just go through your home find
all the good stuff you don't use like
the phone in the drawer the jeans you
wore that one time the handbag that you
didn't even know that you had and you
don't want anymore
in the back your closet then you take a
few pics you add a description and boom
your items are connected to millions of
buyers it's super easy Macari even
emails you a shipping label when it
sells you can even use Macari to buy
gifts too with millions of sellers you
never know what treasures that you'll
find and the app has over 500,000
reviews on the App Store with an average
4.8 star rating so why not give it a try
finally an app that makes you money
check out Macari and lighten the load
this holiday that's Emme are ciear i
Macari the selling app alright we're
back with tableau before we get into
these Twitter questions I'm gonna ask
you the two questions asked every single
guest that is on the podcast and the
first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti act
cold spaghetti at yeah so I'm assuming I
have to like hate this person it's up to
you it can be celebratory if you want it
to be um Thomas Edison
we've never had Thomas Edison as an
answer okay Thomas Edison any any reason
why I mean like he's a great inventor
just like shake him up we owe him a lot
you know but he did certain experiments
with animals uh-huh you know for you to
get ahead okay and I gotta throw some
spaghetti Adam for though Wow okay and
but I will also tell them you know thank
you for the light bulb and thank you but
also like thank you there were better
ways to figure this my daughter will be
like daddy I love you okay the other
question is every single guest is to
tell us your worst pants [ __ ] story
or a close call but you can only use
three words or small phrases so for
example mine is college jogging front
lawn okay yeah
Vancouver paper route
Vancouver paper route yes
alright no follow-up questions let
everyone fill in the blanks for
themselves okay let's get into these
Twitter questions Tablo mentions in his
podcast he's working on new music and
it's going great
please ask him to elaborate on that for
us I lied alright I say that once in a
while when I feel like my fans think
that I'm not working on biggest slacker
and I'm just like on podcast talking
about crazy aliens and stuff so I'm like
I'm just reassuring them that I am
constantly working on music okay yeah
but it's not like you know we are
working on a lot of stuff but it's not
to the point where I can be like you
know soon like coming soon oh I imagine
I'm no musician not even close to that
world at all mmm but you have to be
inspired right like you can't just force
it yeah and you got a like the
songwriter that I am the stuff I talk
about I need to actually live a life
yeah have experiences to be able to
reflect on and make actual art I have
like heartbreak yeah and go to Urgent
Care
which I yes these are two very different
things that you just say the inspiration
for your music heartbreak I get that
urgent care Urgent Care which I had to
go to yesterday and I don't have
insurance over here obviously right
because I live in Korea and they told me
it could cost up to $1,000 okay just for
a check-up
that I desperately needed but I'm saying
well thank you for being here today and
also should you not be here they told me
it's completely uh not contagious
okay hearing that you tell people that
you're working on music and that's kind
of a lie you telling me that's not
contagious I don't just see experiences
like this or needed yeah for me to write
the heartbreaking songs that I write
yeah I need to be in ye'are sometimes I
really really hope that your next song
is called urgent care yeah or whatever
condition I had I am suffering from I
mean you're writing the lyrics as your
dog yeah yes okay if you were to let
your wife marry an Avenger which one
would it be
it would be Doctor Strange really yes
yes why you know like it would just be
easier to take secure assuming that like
so she's married to me now but it is a
little way let's say uh let me kind of
rephrase it let's say your wife gets a
Hall Pass she gets to sleep with an
Avenger who would it be
not marry just have maybe I even sleep
just have like a romantic night with not
the Hulk anyone man so that I wouldn't
even know right
okay I they even be there at the time I
wouldn't know what's day-to-day life
like being the father of the coolest kid
in the world she wakes me up yeah and
then I you know all hell ensues like
immediately oh sure
she's very very energetic yeah and
there's just so much that she like
laughs at like she finds everything
funny that's great yeah which I love
because and actually right before I came
to LA we spent like four hours on
YouTube just watching random YouTube
videos and being like confused by them I
put up a little bit of an Instagram
uh-huh but like that's literally what we
do like she plays a video she's like dad
look at this video she plays a video and
it's like a weird cat or something right
and she's like why I'm so confused and
she goes to the next video she's like
I'm so confused it's literally just me
and my boyfriend getting high at night
watching and for hours just goes by
that's so sweet
so that's what we do someone's no what
is your philosophy my philosophy is be
good to people what work hard and that's
pretty much all you need I mean yeah I
agree
named an artist you've been currently
loving or would think other people would
enjoy listening to currently loving as
in like a new artist I mean this I say
open-ended it can be someone that
everyone knows uh currently loving
strangely enough I've currently loved
Bob Dylan really yeah cool i I used to
really like Bob Dylan as a kid and in
like high school yeah and then I fell
out of love with Bob Dylan when I
recently found out that he was making a
whiskey you fell out of love yeah
knowing that he was making a whisk it
was a couple years ago he had just won
like the Nobel
yeah lid price which was monumental
yeah and immediately decided to make a
whiskey bread
okay he's turned you off he's in the
endorsement of the whiskey Brad yeah
it's like a picture of him making the
whiskey yeah okay and I was like I was
like wait he just won the Nobel Prize
for Literature right and the next move
he's a whiskey breath I mean how you not
see this is an obvious move yeah and I
think the whiskey is called heaven's
door and I'm like oh my god right so I
fell out of love because it was sold out
I mean he got the rulebook on selling
out yeah it was it was jarring for me
yeah but recently I was like hey you
know like would I be able to not do a
whiskey brand like if I won the Nobel
Prize you know would I not right go
crazy
well would you not is that an avenue
that you wouldn't go down even if you
the Nobel Prize wasn't even in the
picture like do I not want a whiskey
break yeah maybe that's your problem
and I started listening to him again
like heavily to make up for the judge
judgmental last time yes yes oh that's
great I'm glad that his actual music
that has you know created his whole
foundation of get amazing brought you
back yes yes now I want to try that
whiskey I'm not even a whiskey I
endorsed him yeah you did it
look you accidentally gave him a tiny
commercial yes what is the weirdest
superstition that you unconsciously
believe in weirdest superstition I
believe I don't know if this is a
superstition but I I believe that like
if you keep saying something it happens
oh like manifesting yeah like speaking
things into into being like you're gonna
have a whiskey line you're gonna have a
whiskey yeah yeah I'm gonna have a
whiskey line yeah and this is not a
superstition but it it gets in the way
of a lot of work sometimes because I I'm
so fixed on that
yeah like during meetings and stuff
if someone says anything negative yeah
like even though it is something that
needs to be said at the time
yeah and point it out that you're like I
don't want to hear it yeah like I don't
want to hear it say it in your head
don't say it out loud don't say it don't
say you just said it's gonna happen now
and they're like I'll take it back you
can't take your packets it's already
been said and I just wait for it to
happen right now and my waiting is
probably what's causing it you're
manifesting it yeah so that's like the
only kind of superstition I have I want
to sit in on a business meeting with you
now it's super positive it's only
patience for everything everyone's
dancing on eggshells yeah and I don't
tell him anything bad what's a crazy
habit that your daughter has a crazy
habit or weird habit I don't know if
it's a weird habit
she calls me well she she used to call
me dude that's sweet so she went from
dad to dude that's really cute actually
I think it's a thing for her to catch up
with the you know with the current word
of endearment yeah cuz one day she was I
I I did something and she thought it was
funny she was like you laughing and
she's like that's so funny bro so she
started calling me bro and then she
called me bro at a certain point and it
just keeps changing what she calls me so
is she like some California surfer I've
no idea I don't know where she's getting
it but um like every time it changes I
assume you know that's what kids call
each other now it's endearing and
degrading at the same time any genre is
epic I would like to try out that they
haven't done before maybe like smooth
jazz uh the only well what I would like
to try like like death metal horrorcore
really yeah like have you guys ever
talked about that kind of thing well one
of my men
when I discovered him in Korea was doing
a short stint as as a member of a
horrorcore group a quick stint yeah and
it was like really really local chords
shredding that was the met metal it
melody yeah that was the hook yeah I
just I just did the hook for you and the
lyrics were about like just horrifying
things that only like belong in a
Stephen King yeah world the darkest dark
yeah just really dark like nails like
judgment like crosses like just just
insane things right that he probably
didn't really even care about yeah right
cuz he was a kid so I and I want to go
back to that with him like that journey
I feel like now's the time and I feel
like I would be a very good like Gothic
like like 300 year old vampire right
yeah total rebranding this feels like
the next thematic tour that yeah yeah
take and I think a lot of epic eyes
music if you'd nudge it a little bit to
the dark side a little bit more you
could become that yeah so we would do
something like very like emotional
horror death metal hip hop I mean just
it's right therefore it's a horrible
stew of like it's right that horrible
stew is a great name for an album or
something to say yes okay last question
any advice that you would give to
aspiring musicians it's actually what I
said earlier but like that's my like
mantra or what I tell myself just be
good to people work really hard yeah and
learn to do something that requires like
absolutely nothing of you but like means
a lot to someone else okay if you make a
habit of doing that yeah like it's like
if you enjoy your job you never work a
day in your
yeah like there's nothing you're gonna
get out of what you're doing at that
second but but like let's say it doesn't
take that much away from you yeah to do
something for this person mm-hmm
but it means like the world to them
that's and if you make it a habit to do
that every day mm-hmm like guaranteed
amazing things happen within you know
months or within the year yeah and I
tell artists you know like it's not all
about just being perfect at your craft
right right it's about like connecting
with other humans connecting with fans
and being authentic and if you just
learn to do that like it requires truly
nothing to make your fans smile once a
once in a while right or to post
something on Twitter that's like two
seconds out of your life that you can
make them feel better for the day yeah
and I tell them just do that and it all
comes back somehow well it's also those
are the people that are supporting you
that are getting you into the level that
you're at so you have to pay them their
due diligence little bit one's buying
your whiskey buying your death metal
you're horrible sellout merch that's
very sweet I think that's very
encouraging okay before you go every
guess that's on the podcast gets a
personalized fortune cookie from us to
them so template this is yours right of
course you can get something good I do
too
I always get the like you know the
statement yeah that's like not helping
me at all well this is really long yeah
this is a reminder to bring producer
Diane a pack of white claw back to Seoul
because she is deathly curious as to
know what all the hype is about this is
a strangely specific fortune Wow
how weird well strange that it works out
that way hey sir Diane is someone that I
know oh wow white claw
what is that Oh
oh man you're now gonna see that
everywhere you go now that you've heard
it wait close to spike Seltzer it's like
a little can of seltzer that has alcohol
in it and it's like flavored like
raspberry and lime and all these things
and it's become very popular it's right
it's like super popular right now yeah
it's almost now going over the edge of
being like too trendy popular that all
these other companies are creating their
own versions of it oh my god it's like
the four local of now yeah yeah it's
it's undeniably refreshing obviously too
much okay we're getting it today yeah
you guys I mean before you leave you
have to take some back or try it while
you're here okay
tablo thank you so much for making time
and I hope you're not contagious I'm not
a few I the four people that have no
idea where can they find you online
where can they hear your music where can
they see what epic eyes ups you I mean
all you have to do is just go to your
favorite like search engine and search
epic hi epi k uh-huh and then hi and
it'll pop up okay and then you listen to
us check out our videos or you just type
in the Tablo and like it automatically
blurts out the Tablo podcast there you
go and you go and you listen is so
simple it's very simple very simple
thank you for the step-by-step process
again thank you for being here thank you
so much of course we'll see you guys
next time another episode of not too
deep goodbye to deep toe deep deep deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer Melissa D
months camera operator Katrina Henning
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]